on monday
the full madden ratings came out
and you know we've had several stories
at profootballtalk.com about the madden
ratings and there there are plenty of of
readers who who don't care about i i
care about it because
it gets players so fired up and it's no
different than someone in the media
criticizing a player and we've seen that
if it's colin coward going after baker
mayfield and baker mayfield gets
motivated he gets upset he engages
coward people talk about that well the
madden machine even though there isn't a
specific name or face attached to it
other than john madden although
everybody knows he's not the one coming
up with these numbers there's somebody
out there that we don't know who it is
that's coming up with these numbers
and
some players are pissed off and it's
it's kind of entertaining and it's kind
of amusing and you have to wonder
what kind of extra motivation it
supplies to a guy in his mid-20s who
thinks he's been disrespected by a video
game he's been playing since he was five
years old i mean that's the ultimate
disrespect you have been a loyal and
faithful consumer of the madden game
every year when it comes out you get the
next version and the next version and
the next version
and they slap you in the face whether
it's demarcus lawrence calling on
cowboys fans to boycott the game because
of his rating eric ebron complaining
about his rating there's a video of
keenan allen of the chargers driving in
his car complaining about his rating
it's a and and i i i really do think
there's a basis for some complaints here
by various players especially at the
quarterback position we wrote about this
yesterday
it's the golden age of quarterbacks
right now in the nfl
and and it's like the they needed a bell
curve or something when they rank the
quarterbacks because there are some guys
who are far lower than they should be
and there aren't nearly enough
quarterbacks in the 90s i think seven
are rated 90 or higher there are there
are more than seven 90 rated
quarterbacks out there right now in the
nfl and i think at other positions you
could make the same argument but i know
they try to create some separation among
the teams
the end result is it
it creates some bad feelings with some
players but it also gets people talking
about the madden game as the madden game
gets ready to be released so
maybe ea wins yet again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports